do not
buy a property without first watching
this video hey what's up my name's
samuel leeds i'm a property investor and
i recently had to save somebody from
buying a terrible property that could
have ended up costing them tens and tens
of thousands of pounds completely down
the drain and in this video i want to
tell you this do not
buy a property unless you have first
watched this video to the end do not buy
a property unless you have first smashed
the like button on this video so go
ahead smash the like button on the video
watch the video till the end and let me
tell you a horror story about a guy
called peter who almost
got busted so i'm about to go to bed
and i'm just scrolling through instagram
and i get an instagram message and i
look at the instagram message and it's a
guy called peter hi peter if you're
watching this you know who you are peter
messaged me on instagram and peter said
samuel i'm thinking of bidding on this
and he just there's a link under the
hammer okay an auction property i'm
thinking a bidding what do you think and
i'm like oh man okay let's have a look
click on the property i look at it and
the property is filled with red flags i
looked at it i had a quick glance yes
it's 11 30 p.m and i'm in bed ready to
just chill and go to sleep with my wife
but i can't not respond to peter because
if peter buys this property or bids on
this property and wins it he could be
busted so i'm going to tell you the five
things that were picked up the five
things not one thing not two things not
three things there's five problems with
this property okay so the first thing to
bear in mind is it was an auction
property what happens if you bid on an
auction property and you win the bid
what happens is you have to buy the
property you can't pull out not only do
you have to buy but you have to buy it
within 28 days usually so you've got to
get the cash so this is serious this is
not child's play so i'm looking at the
property and i could see some serious
issues with the legal pack
it didn't quite look right it was clunky
there was bits that looked contradictory
bits that looked missing so i responded
to peter i dropped peter a voice note
and i said peter
don't bid on this property until you
have spoken to your property solicitor
speak to a conveyancer and and ask them
to look at the legal pack peter
responded with a thumbs up he said sure
i'm thinking you better not beard he
better not bid so the next day i get a
message off of peter in the morning
peter said holy moly thank you for
saving my ass i'm like come on what
happened man so peter phones me up this
is just an instagram follower he's not a
student i don't know peter i'm now
chatting with peter on instagram voice
noting each other back and forth and he
said to me that this listener picked up
five things and these are things that
you need to look for crazy legal
problems that can happen i can't believe
it's even legal to just sell properties
like this although if you enjoy the
video hit like hit like number one so
the property is sold as is
which is kind of normal that's standard
no problem that just means that it's
sold as is there's no comeback
but
the terms and conditions clearly state
that you cannot rely on the description
or the sales
brochure you can't rely on it what does
that mean that means that if the
pictures are wrong if the floor plan is
completely incorrect if the property is
completely mis-sold
you have to sign a waiver to say that's
okay that's a bit of a red flag
because that could mean that in the
description it says something completely
wrong
so you have to basically just ignore
everything that's in the sales brochure
right the description the floor plans
everything you just have to ignore it
number two the legal pack was severely
uncompleted
okay now what does that mean that means
that they didn't give
information that's important to have one
of the bits of information that peter
said was missing was who owns the
property
the solicitor said there was confusion
over who even is the seller it wasn't
clear that's a red flag right there
that's a bit of a problem but
it gets worse number three there was no
guarantee that the property was being
sold with vacant possession what does
that mean that means that normally when
you're selling a property they'll say
it's being sold with vacant possession
so you're buying the property empty
this property did not say that this
property there was no talk about who was
in the property there was no talk of
tenancies so peter looked into it and
guess what the property did have
somebody in it not a tenant
squatter
imagine that imagine buying a house
and then realizing that there's a
squatter in the house
oh my goodness okay that was problem
three it gets worse problem number four
there was a hidden fee of ten thousand
pounds
on top of the purchase price that goes
direct to the seller
okay number five this is the worst one
wait for it this is crazy i can't even
comprehend this oh my goodness i'm
getting hot right now number five is the
property
is being sold
with
a mortgage
[Music]
peter's solicitor said the seller was
not obligated
in the sale to remove the financial
charge prior to the completion so that
literally means that there's a chance
that peter buys the property two hundred
thousand pounds
but then there's a mortgage for a
hundred and fifty thousand pounds
the p that is crazy so what's the
solution well obviously peter did not
buy the house there was too many
problems and red flags and ifs and buts
and maybes and just some serious
devastating things like squatters in the
house but what it means is when you're
buying a property especially from
auction make sure that you get a
solicitor to read through the legal pack
before you bid this is huge also
when you're buying a property please
don't buy it blind there was a story in
the newspaper recently i couldn't
believe i've just seen it from the metro
about a property looks like quite a nice
little property looks nice oh what's
that in the background it looks like in
the background there is a
pylon a giant pylon in the background
guess what that's not in the background
that is in the back garden oh my
goodness so the property was being
advertised of course they did not use
this picture and you know you would you
could easily miss it so don't rely on
pictures a picture they say a picture
tells a thousand stories but actually i
believe a picture sometimes paints a
thousand lies don't rely solely on the
picture get down to a property look at
it in person have a survey on it get a
legal pack looked at by a solicitor
before you bid before you offer on a
property this is called due diligence
and this is all part of the process that
you need to know before by property so i
hope you enjoyed this video hit like
subscribe and i'll see you next time
[Music]